[Musique]
j'arrive j'arrive au nom tient merci non
un pays ne vaut que par la qualité de
ses dirigeants laissez les tranquilles
un vrai roi est brave et noble joue pas
les héros je suis roi ici tu as encore
d'autres combats à mener à présent tu
dois choisir
[Musique]
ce pourquoi tu te bats les doors regarde
ce que j'ai trouvé quelque chose est
écrit sur la garde va voir sur google
traduction
ça veut dire l'épée d'arthur et si tu
étais la seule personne qui pouvait
retirer cet ep et si c'était excalibur
[Musique]
enfin suivez moi je suis merlin je
croyais que berlin était un vieil âge un
ingénieux déguisements n'est ce pas
dans quatre jours la sorcière morgan
s'emparera du monde arrivait souvent mes
guerriers
je suis censé la stopper c'est n'importe
quoi voilà ton épée et je te souhaite
bonne chance pour la suite
tu es un roi alexander les bêtas choisi
pourquoi on t'aidera
vous êtes les gens les plus forts que je
connaisse vous êtes mes chevalier et
c'est la table ronde vite bidders relève
les rabats toi alors tu es trop un geek
c'est le destin
[Musique]
dans toutes les histoires qu'on a lu
luke skywalker harry potter un truc
incroyable arrivent ils découvrent
qu'ils descendent d'une famille aux
pouvoirs magiques
on ne fuit pas d'accord
que ce soit
chose ne soit jamais arrivée
saluons le roi pour l'éternité
non s'il vous plaît ça me gêne
oui ce que tu as appris à conduire mario
kart